alright here we are in overtime for
Maxine Waters what do you think of
criticism of liberal candidates by black
lives matters activist yes they were
yelling at hillary yesterday oh well
this is where I get in trouble with a
lot of people I am a real believer in
First Amendment rights I encourage
people to speak up speak out to organize
to rally and to do all of that you may
not like it but they doesn't sound like
something that would get you in drunk
I'm for the First Amendment I don't care
who knows it
I don't care who knows it yeah so anyhow
they are acting out they're acting up
they're making a lot of people
uncomfortable but as far as I'm
concerned deal with it okay I heard that
all right Roger stone what do you hope
voters will take away from your book the
Clintons war on women you're pretty
tough on the Clintons on this book you
you think Bill Clinton has not always
been a gentleman no that's really not
the point the point is that her
narrative you say he raped 27 you know
he says he is a Bill Cosby type sexual
predator we know some of these names
Juanita Broadwick Paula Jones Kathleen
Willey there are others we don't know
Christie Zurcher a Becky Brown Helen
Doughty and so on I don't and Hillary
has facilitated those yes rape
I don't remember ugly words not what
Paula Jones said somewhat uh no she was
sexually assaulted pardon me but it's
it's just not bad well I don't know if
and it's Hillary who hires the
heavy-handed private detectives to
silence these women well I made the book
no no no one is saying that he's not a
horndog uh my books not about consensual
sex I'm in favor of consensual sex
between adults the idea of cut another
brave stands a Pete
I am for conceptual suck if I wrote a
book about his girlfriends his
mistresses is one-night-stands to beat
encyclopedia this is not the point the
point is he has abused women she's
helped cover it up
she's an enabler that's what the books
about the Clintons are a little handsy
yeah a little rapey well okay I know it
sounds sort of shitty David what do you
make of the news that Holograms of Andy
Kaufman and Redd Foxx will tour comedy
clubs next year [ __ ] I have to follow
that [ __ ] yeah yeah I can't even follow
a juggler I don't follow Richard Pryor
Yeah right
oh great yeah yeah great anyway uh does
the end of the one-child rule in China
yes that's another story we should have
covered ran out of time one China after
35 years of law and that's what you can
do in a dictatorship you can tell people
how many kids they can have now you can
have two but no substance no
substitutions No
that's my hell took me a second yeah
okay
no what no the only thing that bothered
me about that is they wanted boys well
yeah I mean they have a terrible problem
over there and yeah of too many men and
too few women that's right
yeah because infanticide was yeah this
is also making a prison cell a little
bit larger not one to still a government
law
I mean population is one of the biggest
problems we have climate wise just Jimmy
oh no I know not in China then it is
vegan also now here's something people
won't like to hear it's the wrong people
procreating religious people
what are you thinking talking about okay
no I'm just saying we're all you know
real it there's an arms race between
religions we got to get more Catholics
out there we got to get more Muslims out
there it's crazy all right
Grover do you expect that the Republican
nominee whoever he or she is will sign
your anti-tax pledge yes dad they say
just about everybody has I expect both
Trump and Bush the two who haven't yet
both will do it they both said Trump has
said he opposes tax increases that we
just looking to get it in writing to the
American people I think that will happen
and what do you what do you say to the
people who would counter that by saying
that if we don't have enough revenue it
will explode the debt which Republicans
are also claiming that they hate okay if
you keep spending and you dent it you'll
have that we always do keep spending
including the Republicans I mean isn't
that not always that's the whole point
don't have to but we always because
you've had a president controlled by the
special interest that's why you know
it's Congress right but the president
can cut spending if he has the will to
do for the problem is that everyone in
the system is controlled by a special
interests and she'll tell you everything
in the budgets been put there by
somebody but if I smoke every once I get
so okay it's okay not to remember
history but in the last four years we've
dropped spending from 24% of GDP down to
20% of GDP just recently because of the
caps federal spending because of the
caps that were put in and we've held -
with little loosening but they've
they're not gone away they're not giving
Obama credit for something all right it
was it was his idea
Wow and we appreciate it it was a great
little step for so but spending went
down because the caps help but I just
have to keep them on but the fact of the
matter is we had something called
earmarks for example right and there
were a few people talking about we got
to get rid of them and they got rid of
them but I want to tell you Republicans
wanted them as much as Democrats yep
angry and they liked to take the gravy
home or whatever you want to call it and
so it is not as some would say it's
Democrats that spending everybody where
is it not believe me the same
we'll always happen I've heard this my
whole life we have to starve the beast
but what does a beast do it borrows the
Beast never starves I borrow is anybody
believe there's didn't with this many
departments there's no waste there's
hundreds of billions of dollars worth of
waste it's a matter of well that's
another kind of you know we do need to
have on spending that that the key thing
is how much money the government spends
we need to keep that limited but but and
that and then there's not an argument
for raising taxes but you know it's a
very hard argument to make with the
American people because they have no
idea what's in the budget I mean they
think like 25 percent of it goes to
foreign aid when you couldn't find
foreign aid in the budget with the
jeweller's I most of the money in the
budget goes to old people and aircraft
carriers that's what we spend money on
now old people at least paid into it but
Americans don't look at what goes into
defense spending they just hear it and
go oh blank check to the Pentagon of
course we always need more and that's a
place where we could really cut a lot
and not take it and not be any less safe
not in any less safe you should have one
thing to do is invite Congress and
Calvert from California on he has a
piece of legislation that would reduce
the number of civilian employees at the
Pentagon down by about a hundred
thousand saves a great deal of money
hundreds of thousands of billions of
dollars over a decade and it really does
bring both spending down without
endangering or getting out yes sir
that's the hedge fund guys who get away
with not paying their fair
to correct the homeless people off the
streets of this leaf that like that's
about three billion and what right but
our friend Calvert talking about saving
is over 100 yeah no I mean it's a
worthwhile savings to be made and the
Pentagon has not died and they haven't
been helpful and because of the
sequester they're beginning to think
maybe they'll get out of bed and do some
fun I said this to Bernie Sanders when
he was here two weeks ago and the
Liberals got mad at me but you know just
taxing the people with yachts is not
going to come close to what were what
he's wanting to do you're gonna have to
go way down you're gonna have to tax
that's right right okay the actual New
York Times Jonah Hague I mean trillion
in spending and besides we're going to
always raise the debt limit when we have
to and you know so when we talk about
spending and you know basically who's
you're responsible for we're all in this
game together and I tell you I won spend
more money on the homeless what's
happening in LA is shameful you go
downtown LA and the streets are crowded
all the way up to City Hall with folks
who are homeless and until you can talk
about how we spend money on our veterans
who are on the street who have been you
know away in service making sacrifices
until you can talk about taking care of
you know our old folks on Medicare and
making sure that they have the right
health care that they deserve quality
health care then you know I'm not
worried about spending too much money
okay thank you very much thank you
audience you're terrific
we got to go
you